look my friends you can't run away from  who you are you can try to mold yourself  into a politically correct world and  luckily the world is now focusing on  other variables will always have race  and religion and sex in those things but  now we're leveling up even into like  what's a butter dad and like you know  what fit work-life balance to fix that  nature look I know the optics I know I'm  living a public persona I know I have to  answer these questions  I'd like to be politically correct that  I'd like to be perfect I'd like to make  it easy on myself to not have to be  oldest prescient the optics on the  outside here is the punched I promise  you can